have you ever heard of the Midas touch
King Midas King Midas was this guy who
anything he touched turned to gold what
if instead of turning things to gold you
turn them into like Lego blocks [ __ ]
champion we're doing a wrestling video
Sam defending you like that still feel
like this isn't all of our guns no it's
not we have a box ball over here
what is the youtube you speak up
basically you have pictures you playing
fast enough so it appears too much for
me too much
our founding fathers look at that our
founders I know we need a brain matter
with our family that is bigger you need
that like this big Commission I got an
oil painting for my China for like 200
bucks
that's PA baan velvet if you're serious
you already freak know where to get that
that's Sam is a fetus yeah hope you like
it thank Sam there you go
all that work convinced down into sixty
Seconds
wow that looks [ __ ] awesome it's nice
showing it to people and having people
like oh wow I actually want to see that
really happy without turning off will be
like there Hulu there's a there's it
yours go ninety what are the potential
myths so be ten episodes basically it
should be free on there we've been told
it's gonna be free which would be great
because and everybody can go watch it
you have to be a Verizon customer no
just download the app after that
internationally be a film and with this
with us parties yeah 1/4 inch soda and
chips for [ __ ] everybody
such Pop feel crazy you know [ __ ]
jacked on the old sugar so I started
experimenting today with right how can
we convert 3d models into Lego brick
models this software is called Bricker
without the e apparently software needs
to be named without vowels basically
what this does I'm just gonna load up a
3d models make a teapot here look at
that and so it's very short and Extra
Stout actually whoo now I want some
beard on a good chocolate stout right
now
I'm a real pirate load up any 3d model
you want and it'll automatically box
allies it for you that's the act of like
turning it into basically cubes now we
have this sweet looking teapot that's
all brick
I threw it through at quite little
physics simulations so it actually falls
to the ground but because there's
literally like three thousand bricks I
think a little render intensive so
that's a good thing to know lots of
bricks will be slow to Oh work with
proof as far as like a proof-of-concept
this is really cool but the next step is
rendering and that's why I love octane
so much is because it renders not only
super fast but super cool looking ah
look at that
instantly loaded so the main thing I
learned today about this is that for
whatever reason it causes some extreme
slowdown and maybe it's because of the
sheer it not can't be it's not using
that much memory but right now it's
frozen it's literally frozen I can't do
anything after another five to ten
minutes it'll come back it's like great
it didn't actually crash but lose ten
minutes of work that's what chocolates
outs are for I prefer a vanilla oatmeal
stout from a Ninkasi right dude
organ breweries the best we got the
shoots we got Road we got super Sam hold
him like this
yep like wants to me don't mess my hair
[ __ ] oh no I might have found like my
calling I want to do drugs now I haven't
done drugs in years ritual this makes
you want to do drugs is this good for
the kids at home oh yes it's great for
kids great for kids you go you're the
[ __ ] worst oh that's just
oh my god
brushes thick paint I love the word
thick scream now I'm black
ah now I'm in no wow fish minnows whoa
that's beautiful it's like I've never
experienced that before do you feel sort
of euphoric you've been sober you
haven't been both there
wow you really like it it's a giddy
feeling like you feel so cool dude it's
it's the future man yeah 15 to 28 yeah
look here put that one on this whoa